richie tayyip erdogan campe sur ses
positions il ne cédera pas sur
l'adhésion de la suède et de la finlande
à l'otan
nous ne dirons pas oui
à l'adhésion à l'organisation de
sécurité autant de ceux qui appliquent
des sanctions contre la turquie damas le
président turc fait référence à une
mesure prise par la suède et la finlande
en 2019 stockholm et helsinki ont
suspendu toute vente d'armes à ankara en
représailles à son opération militaire
contre les forces kurdes en syrie
recep tayyip erdogan leur reproche aussi
de soutenir le parti des travailleurs du
kurdistan le pkk considéré en turquie
comme une organisation terroriste
la finlande et la suède n'ont pas donné
suite à 33 demandes d'extradition
d'individus réclamé par ankara
je dois dire une chose très clairement
et très ouvertement
aucun de ces deux pays là de position
claire
contre les organisations terroristes
est ultra ce qu'on nous dit un discours
qui tranche avec les propos de la
diplomatie turque ce dimanche elle avait
affirmé ne pas fermer la porte à
l'entrée des deux pays nordiques dans
l'otan
helsinki et stockholm auront besoin de
l'approbation de tous les alliés pour
faire partie de l'organisation
une délégation diplomatique suédoise
doit se rendre lundi prochain à ankara